nous attendions depuis longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces séances sont obligatoires pour tout
le monde s'arrache
ma mère souffrait de dépression à nice
je peux entrer marché
même si je n'étais qu'une enfant je
savais que c'était amie ouvre la porte
ils doublaient plus que ça
allait ma mère disait qu'elle entendait
une voix dans sa tête
et que cette voie ne la voulez pas elle
elle me voulez moi
la citadelle est tombé une fumée noire
masquer le soleil certains d'entre vous
le savent déjà nous avons une femme qui
vient étudier dans cette classe
seulement en tant qu'observatrice
descendons dans les entrailles de
l'enfer si vous le voulez bien
il y a plus de possession signalé de nos
jours que dans toutes les autres époques
de l'histoire nous devons combattre pour
sauver chaque arbre
[Musique]
défendue dans le combat contre les
esprits de la malveillance
je pense que le démon qui tourmentait
nathalie est celui qui possède elle-même
mère sont en fait le même
j'aimerais enseigner ce sera le minimum
requis pour se protéger elle même et les
autres
la relation qu'elle a
et très personnel
note attendu en depuis longtemps
[Musique]
tamer a une très belle voix
ya quelqu'un
soyez prudentes maintenant que vous
connaissez le diable
le diable vous connaît aussi
[Musique]